IT'S BEING FOUGHT HERE TO THE
FFORTTECT DEMOCRACYN THE UNITE.
JANUARY h
OR
URTTEE
ERARTMENT GH
CTING AN OFF CY TO
UNITED
IST
DO Y H EVIDENCE TO
REFER UM
CHARGES?
>> WELL, WE
DEON REFERRALS O
I THINK IT IS ABSOLU THE SE ABS
R OF PEOPLE OUHIM WERE DOING, A
UL.
T ANYWI THINYOU CERTAINLY SAW T
LIKELY THAN NOT THAT THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES
WAS ENGAIN CRIMINA
ORGANIZED ANDWELL-PLANNED EFFO
MULTIPLE TOOLS TO TRY TOELECTIO.
DAYS A PLEA AGREEMENT FR
OF LRS IN REALLY
HA THE DAY AFTE RE, BEILD,ON'TA
TION AND THEPLANNIED, AND AT TH
THATY OING TTO U O TR
POWER.
THE DEFINITION OAN
T IS TELYE CLEAR,'V
E AND YOU BELIEVE TRUMP COMMITT
IS A PUBLIC MENT IN THE OTED TOO
DONOHOE CASE
EVERYBODY CALOIT
I WOULECOMMEND
EVERYBODY DOES LOOK  IT.
IT'S THE SE INA AGREEMT.E COMMI
D DOCUMENTS THAT IHINK VERY,
VERY CLEARLY DEMONSTRA
E PLAN THE GANIZATION ABJECTIVE
AND THE OBJEIVS ABSOLULYTO T CO
ECRYRF
KNEW WHAT THERG WAS UNLAWFULANDD
O
A REFERRAL WHICH ACTUALLY HAS N
THE PROCESS UNDEWHICH ATTORNEY
GENERAL MERRICK GARLAND MIGHT LN
ARGUNTRI
E HAS THE T HAS.
WHERE DO YOU COME DOWN?
>> THERE'S NOT RLLA DISPON THE E
THE COMMITTE WORKING IA
REALLY COLO S THESES AS WE
ADDRESSING AND WE'LL CONTINUE TO
DO SO.
WOULDN'T CHAERERE
BEING A UTE ON
COMMITE.
THE SINGLE MOST
COLLATIVE COMMITTEE ON WCH
E BIIS ER SERVED
RAEGT.
L OFTHE ISSUES THAT WE'RFACING.
DIUTS ISE.>> FORMER PRESIDENT TT
MMITTEE FOR EIGHT S THY HELPFUL?
DID SHE SHED ANY NEW LIGHT
THE CRUCURS WHILE THERMONY WAS
BEEN THE
TEIM OF
HERS WHO HAVPEARED IN
FRONT OF THE COMMITTEEJUT REALL
SCAVINO ANTEH REGARD ROW
TO MOVE TO CONARY WE WERE RIGH
AGAIT F THEM.ABSOLUTELY NO PRIV
THIS COUNTRY THAT IS AN
ANDALCOND TESTIFY,
COCOIT
PA UNDER THESE
CIRCUMSTANCES.
CONTINUE TO WO
AGAIN, WE'RE INCREDIBL
GTE
AND AN THE MANY,
HAPPED SURABWHO HAVERESPONSIBILD
NEVER HAPPENS AGAIN.EPUBLICAN  K
IIN
THINHEN .ED ATAN
INVITINGE ATIC UKRAINE
M  YOU FEEL
THERE'S AN THEREFAE HA
EFFORTS TO GO TH OF TO OVERTURN
THECON IN TH STATES.I WOULY IS
UKRAINE IS
DEMORAAT
ACY MU
TH EE OF A
POSITI SO
OBLITI TNKEADER McCA
HAD
HIS OATH TTI
POLITICAL GAINS,HINK
BUD R  THE DAYEAS IS RESPONSIBLI
IF WE DON'TFOFREEDOM,F WED
N INDIVIDUAL, WE